ربما
يمكن العثور على المبنى الأكثر مرونة في العالم في
نهر اليانغتسي في الصين حيث كان يقف على
مدار السبعمائة عام الماضية
[موسيقى]
جناح وانيان المعروف أيضًا باسم
جناح آلهة الرحمة هو معبد
يقع في مدينة حديقة حيوان في الصين
تعود أصول مقاطعة هوبي إلى
عهد سلالة الأمم المتحدة ، وهو المعبد الوحيد الذي تم بناؤه على
نهر اليانغتسي الذي يبلغ طوله 4000 ميل تقريبًا ،
ويقع المعبد على صخرة شعاب مرجانية كبيرة
في النهر خلال موسم الأمطار
، وغمر أساس المعبد
بالماء ويبدو المبنى.  كما لو كان الجناح
عائمًا
اليوم ، فإن الجناح ليس مفتوحًا
للجمهور ، لكن هذا لا يمنع
السباحين المغامرين من استكشاف
الهيكل بينما جرفت الفيضانات
والعواصف الممطرة الغزيرة الأشجار
والمزيد من الهياكل الحديثة أجنحة جوان يين
لا تزال قوية إنها
شهادة على
الهندسة المعمارية لأسلافها
[تصفيق]